l'un des mouvements d'extrême droite au
canada et au québec une cible a pignon
sur rue à québec
l'atalante 15 son discours bull tra
droite par des gestes humanitaires comme
une campagne récente sur le web où elle
se filmer en train de tendre de la
nourriture aux démunis
[Musique]
un prix alors que c'est fermé
m
mais si vous écoutez bien les paroles
scande la radicalisation
il y aurait dû tout au plus quelques
centaines d'individus vraiment actif
c'est mouvement de l'ultra-droite au
québec principalement des skinheads
néonazis
mais combien sont ils à partager leur
idéologie très difficile à dire
leur petit nombre après cependant une
dimension plus importante sur la place
publique depuis la tragédie de
charleville et propos de trempe
ici aussi catapulte ces gens vers une
plus grande notoriété
on apprenait cette semaine par exemple
la parti d'extrême droite pourrait se
retrouver sur les bulletins de vote aux
prochaines élections générales au québec
en 2018
sébastien poirier fondateur du mouvement
traditionaliste du québec d'y avoir
réservé un autre parti auprès du
directeur général des élections du
québec va par contre on voit à long
terme donc relativement poirier est
d'avis que la culture québécoise est
menacé par le nombre de migrants qui ne
sont pas la couleur de la majorité
contre cette idée massive de la vie
marine
[Musique]
on vise plutôt à intégrer davantage et
ce sont les anciens raciste réforme et
qui comprennent le mieux
l'impulsion nous 20 des groupes de
l'ultra droite ici même au québec
et comment le web vient kalbani zeller
energy beja la première chose qu'on voit
sur la page de la scène québécois de
souche
une nouvelle no job mais sont tout seuls
bs au genre de comparaisons douteuses
que les racistes contre pau
l'immigration maxime fiset et l'ex
fondateur du site web de la fédération
des québécois de souche cettex
suprémacistes collabore maintenant avec
le centre québécois de prévention de la
radicalisation menant à la violence
jamais ils vont parler d'art que boutade
le g15 zanon n'est pas raciste contre
une religion l'islam mais on constate si
on suit leur fils assez longtemps sont
également de suite mais ils vont
simplement s'en cacher c'est une bonne
en plus des propos qui sont ouvertement
raciste
ils vont chercher à édulcorer leur
secours je suis d'ailleurs c'est
l'objectif que j'avais moi même quand
j'étais le chef de cette organisation là
et d'une choriste du sco pour le rendre
plus politiquement correct ce qui est
paradoxal parce qu'en même temps ils
dénoncent le politiquement correct et
ils vont presque tous voter conservateur
certainement voter pour le bloc
mais sur la scène québécoise la cac et
relativement populaire aussi en colère
que le gaucher de se positionner un peu
comme un peu comme un tram soft il y
avait joué un peu là-dessus lui il
faudrait rouvrir la question
d'immigration n'est pas encore de groupe
politique visible très visible se
tiennent un discours d'extrême droite
mais il ya des tentatives comme deux
troncs nationale en ce moment j'ai
fédération des québécois de souche
atalante québec qui est qu un groupe de
skinheads de la région de québec très
actifs sont révisés une forme de
propagande
ces vidéos l'eau circule étonnamment
beaucoup ce discours s'inscrit dans
l'appel du populisme de droite
donc c'est à dire ils ont toujours
tendance à faire une dichotomie entre
eux et nous francis langlois et
chercheur associé à l'observatoire des
états unis à la chaire raoul dandurand à
l'université du québec à montréal
toujours cet aspect laqué très
catastrophe si ce temps donc c'est
quelque chose qui arrive une crise il
faut agir maintenant une victimisation
assez forte 6 de la majorité dont quand
on est victime des autres on obtient du
gouvernement
évidemment dans tout bon discours
populiste il ya une vinification de
l'élite c'est à dire que les politiques
et économiques peu importe est toujours
plus est un complot
de l'élite pourrait servir la population
que ce soit pour des réformes
économiques ou encore par une
immigration massive qui va faire
descendre les conditions de vie
mouvement d'extrême droite gagne en
popularité au québec et ses groupes se
mobilisent devant l'arrivée de
demandeurs d'asile les affiches anti
immigration avec le mot clic hashtag
l'immigration ont fait leur apparition
dans la ville de québec tout le québec
en fait n'est pas immunisé contre la
montée du radicalisme attisée par le
populisme politique
un reportage de radio canada
international